Starbucks is leading the war on
Christmas in America,
or is it just a stupid Red Cup chick fil
a's?
Owner hates gay people,
or is he just for family values?
Donald Trump's twitter is a place for
him to speak his mind or is it just the
place for the ramblings of a lunatic?
I don't even need a cell phone.
My thoughts are sent directly to the
Internet.
Now I can reach out to their followers
and tell them where without the
government,
what do all these things have in common?
Well,
they all have been helped by
controversy.
If you don't believe me,
let's run through them.
Starbucks stock price shot up after the
Red Cup was announced,
chick filet had record breaking sales
that year and Donald trump is the
president.
And why is this happening?
Why does controversy always seemed to
benefit someone?
We're going to talk about all of this
and more,
but first,
let me say that controversy has a fine
line to tread.
There needs to be a believable,
credible viewpoint on both sides.
So when you hear that Adam Sandler has
had a controversial movie career since
his horror movie,
Jack and Jill,
that's not true because everyone agrees
it's been bad,
but it might be controversial to say
whether he still has a soul after
selling it for cash.
Someone say you can't forget about happy
Gilmore.
Others would say,
yeah,
but Pixel.
Okay.
So to explain how controversy works,
first we have to talk about social
media.
Social media sites have become the
gatekeepers of what will be popular next
and they have a problem.
They have millions of posts each day and
need a way to allow good posts to rise
to the top and limit the reach of
bandwidth.
And because of this,
what all social media sites having
common is that they heavily reward
interaction and the reason is simple.
How else can a social media site no to
promote something unless you click or
type something that essentially says,
Hey,
I found this post to be worth my time to
click my mouse or type on my keyboard.
So maybe others will too.
And there's a hierarchy of interaction.
It depends on the site,
but basically the rule of thumb is
whatever people tend to do least is the
most valuable.
So for example,
comments are better than likes on
facebook because people tend to comment
less so it shows a higher level
engagement that someone would comment
and that's why in social media what's
more important than consensus is
conversation.
So with all that in mind,
let's talk about controversy traps.
This is where controversy gets its
power.
There are controversy traps we fall into
that make us accidentally promote
something when we're actually trying to
make fun of them or argue their points.
This is because controversial things are
heavily interactive.
They bait you into responding.
If you see something that strikes you as
crazy or wrong,
it's easy to want to respond,
but no matter how you do it,
it's only helping that controversy grow.
Even if you type up a comment,
I totally hate this,
go die to facebook,
Insta,
whatever.
What you're actually saying to the
social media site is,
I'm engaged and interested in this,
but there's another important element
that helps make controversy so powerful.
It's the comment reply.
Once people start commenting on other
comments and generating entire back and
forth arguments,
that is pure dopamine to your social
network,
it's also fairly unique to controversial
topics and a video with consensus by
replied to someone over and over if you
agree with it.
For most of us,
it's only when we disagree with someone.
Do we ever come at once much less
several times,
so when you think you're arguing
throwaway account,
1140 on the Internet on why that piece
of content should have never been made.
You're actually smashing the like button
over and over.
The second controversy trap is even
worse.
It's the response article or video to
the controversial topic.
This happens a lot where people will
share and opposing take on a piece of
news or a person's actions,
which doesn't seem like a share because
they're taking the other side,
but just like in the case of comments,
you're actually feeding the beast
because now your talking about something
controversial.
This will intern drag people in from the
other side and the cycle continues.
As long as there's someone to argue with
and the more controversial video is,
the more these controversial traps are
hard to avoid and when controversial
topics are raking in tons of views,
this intern give that person more
incentive to make videos like that,
which is why it's somewhat ironic when
people complain that such ridiculous
topics gets so much attention,
they're getting attention in part
because you're commenting on them and
complaining about how much attention
they're getting.
So to wrap up this video,
I thought I'd make a quick guide to
disliking anything on social media
because it is so non intuitive.
Don't do anything.
The more outrage or annoyed you are,
the more you should keep your mouth
shut.
Controversial things on social media or
like a tar baby,
react and it only gets worse.
Ignore it and it will go away.
The flip side of this is if you like a
channel and want other people to know
about that channel to you know how to
support it.
If you liked this video,
interact with me and the others in the
comments below,
and if you didn't,
please,
oh,
please leave a mean comment in the
comments section that'll show me.
Thanks for watching.
As a quick footnote,
that didn't make it into the main part
of the video.
One necessary caveat is that some social
media sites are better at suppressing
controversy than others.
For example,
some have disliked systems in place.
That doesn't mean much sense.
In places like youtube,
you can get millions of hits even with
mostly dislikes.
Culver.
In places like Reddit,
they have a very good system of sorting
posts that allows for dislikes,
so depending on the site you're on
disliking a video,
maybe a good alternative to nothing.